and early on your parents kept a lid on
you because you were a talented kid I
mean to get cast in City Slickers how
old are you 11 12. yeah I was 11 11
years old that's a pretty big deal and
that was a huge movie and a great movie
but um you had gotten uh an audition for
Mighty Ducks which was a big big movie
you passed the audition you got the role
your parents put the kill on it yeah
when you're a kid who knows at that age
you want to be an actor Will you again
are you just so [__] disappointed in
your parents for making you turn down
that role yeah I mean I mean it was like
it was that's I mean someone's telling
you to star in a movie it's crazy and
then they say you can't it's like
they're crazy do you throw a tantrum do
you say because I could have whined and
cried my way into that role I definitely
remember like crying on the kitchen
counter right I mean being like what
like you guys are crazy and did your
sister even step in I mean because
Maggie was like
she's not a nice person she was like
laughing at you taunting you I don't
even remember my sister in the equation
I don't even know where she was she was
like she really didn't care but but like
my parents were they were like look
you're about to enter Junior High School
you got to get your education that's the
most important thing I promise you you
hate us now but you know you you'll
you'll thank us later and I was like and
I do I thank them later after City slick
workers I mean your world's gotta kind
of turn upside down because suddenly
like you're in the acting world but your
parents keep you level-headed you even
go off to college right you you finished
high school you go off to college but
then you get into college and it's been
pretty [__] magical because you go to
Columbia and then you drop out because
you got October Sky right well at that
point I actually got that movie when I
was in my senior year in high school
they I had gotten into Columbia early
right and they said all right you can
audition now and I would go in my free
periods when I when I wasn't in class
and I would go and audition and for
about like a year year and a half I was
just I was auditioning for things and
then I got this part that would shoot
after I'd gotten to college the second
semester my senior and I shot it then so
when you decide to drop out you call
your parents to ask them their as
permission which is a weird thing to
have to do because you're at that age
where you're like I could be doing I
could be working and making my own
living yeah but they're paying for my
education right and you want their
approval at the same point absolutely I
think you're at an age where you you're
sort of balancing between what's mine
and what's theirs and what have I been
taught I don't think you're I wasn't so
sure at the time so if your parents had
said to you in that phone conversation
you don't have our blessing we want you
to stay in college would you have done
it no you still would have loved it yeah
I would have left so you basically told
them look man this is it I've got the
acting I remember Mighty Ducks right
[__] you pay back
a professional hockey team after that
movie man I mean like when your parents
forbid you from doing Mighty Ducks did
you go see the film uh when you were a
kid I still have yet to see the film
Howard are you serious I have I hold
such uh you know right did you go see
the film as a kid I I think yes I did
killing us because you knew the part who
got your part dude Emilio Estevez got my
partner no I'm kidding no I got your
part um I don't know you know no I don't
you really don't know did it kill you to
go to the Moon did you say to your
parents let's go see this [__] movie
that I could have been this year we're
all gonna go mom and dad
foreign